le fonds québécois de capital de risque
innovia créé un deuxième grand fond de
croissance 450 millions de dollars
américains provenant de la caisse de
dépôt du fonds ftq d'investissement
québec notamment pour soutenir le
développement d'entreprises
technologiques dans les services
financiers la santé le commerce le
travail le voyage au total innovia
maintenant un milliard et demi de
dollars américains en capital sous
gestion avec des investissements dans
litespeed saunders hopper et d'autres
également avec nous ce soir nous avons
un plaisir de recevoir patrick pichette
qui est le partenaire d'inovia il est à
londres bonsoir patrick pichette
bonsoir vont vous connaissez on vous
connaît bien ici dans les milieux
d'affaires vous avez été le chef de la
direction financière de google
vous êtes actuellement le président du
conseil d'administration de twitter de
lightspeed également et là vous êtes à
londres d'abord je vous pose la question
tout de go comment vous allez monsieur
qui souhaitent quand ça va très bien si
le prêtre ainsi à l'ong les gens qui
sont sorties dans les parcs
c'est de toute beauté de la peau neuve
est vacciné là je suis en fait vacciner
depuis vendredi dernier provient et
deuxième dose ou juste la première
si la première en fait ici en angleterre
ils essaient de faire la première à tout
le monde rapidement
ça fait en sorte que la deuxième est un
peu plus tard mais on s'est tellement la
bonne stratégie
bob un excellent a tant mieux pour vous
vous êtes partenaires du fonds québécois
inovia fonds de capital de risque
d'abord c'est quoi l'objectif d'inovia
innovia c'est une firme de capital de
risque donc à prendre des risques sur
des petites sociétés qui peuvent être
les champions de demain
donc c'est mettre l'argent y mettre les
efforts de support de gestion sur ces
petites sociétés donc des petites
sociétés québécoises canadiennes
essentiellement d'abord oui le cas d'un
avion est vraiment axé sur le canada on
a il faut grâce à une review de la façon
suivante ancré au canada mais on connaît
très bien toute la diaspora canadienne à
silicon valley parce que beaucoup de nos
canadiens québécois qui vont travailler
là et on connaît aussi maintenant avec
une ouverture du
roh de londres il ya quelques années
toute la communauté européenne aussi et
donc vous aider vous soutenez des
entreprises vous investissez dans les
entreprises comme litespeed par exemple
exactement raid fils était tellement bon
exemple inovio avait investi dans
l'atypique ans était tout petit un
kandak c'était encore une petite société
avec une petite équipe dax da silva le
grand patron de leitza fait qu'à dax a
commencé sa société et inovio a investi
alors que c'était une toute société
puis nous avec le fonds de croissance en
2018 on a fait un bon investissement
dans la société light speed avec on
s'est assis avec l'équipe de gestion
on voyait un potentiel pour une vraie
société globale sa demande et des
investissements
cela demandait beaucoup de travail alors
c'est ce qu'on a fait avec le premier
fonds d'investissement du navire et on
est parti d'une petite société qui était
certainement centre et surtout sur
l'amérique du nord puis maintenant c'est
une société complètement globale et vous
donner un chèque de combien dans ce
colloque
combien vous investissez pour que les
entreprises prennent leur envol et on
peut investir le minimum qu'on
investisse et 25 millions puis on peut
aller jusqu'à un cran de milliards s'il
le fallait
et cet argent là vient donc de grands
fonds d'investissement qui vous font
confiance comme la caisse de dépôt fait
confiance à patrick pichette
en fait front contre 1,7 toute l'équipe
d'inovio parce que c'est une équipe qui
est bien rodée qui a fait ses preuves
puis innovia ça fait quand même depuis
2007 qui est établi à montréal alors
déjà depuis longtemps une bonne relation
avec la caisse de dépôt ou
investissement québec où tous nous nous
les gens qui nous supportent et ce
qu'ils font c'est essentiellement deux
choses inouïes nous nous font confiance
avec le portefeuille qu'ils nous donnent
puis en plus de ce qu'ils vont faire ça
ils vont nous dire si vous avez des
investisseurs vous avez besoin
d'investissements additionnels
on est là pour vous avec la bonne
stratégie pour faire la croissance
nécessaire c'est quoi votre plus value
dans le marché en ce moment pourquoi
c'est important fonds de capital de
risque comme comme celui duquel vous
êtes partenaires
en fait il n'en est rien c'est très
important pour le québec canada parce
que
on a au canada beaucoup
d'investissements ce que je vais appeler
en linguistique j'en ai tout petit
chèque dans cette affaire un
investissement d'un million de millions
sur les sociétés qui démarre c'est pas
très difficile de trouver cet argent
leur avec sur une bonne idée mais quand
noté kim être d'école comme litespeed
était en 2017-2018 trouver des chèques
de 50 60 75 millions c'est beaucoup plus
difficile au canada puis souvent
l'argent venait des états unis puis avec
cet argent qui menaient des états unis
souvent talent disparaissent et aux
états unis où les compagnies tht
essentielle est-ce que c'est une
invasion de garder nos bonnes idées nos
bonnes idées innovants ici au québec au
canada de de propriété canadienne avec
le siège social ici également
bingo vous avez tous en brie monsieur
fillon c'est ça qu'ils peuplent les plus
importants auxquels elle en ce moment on
a on a les universités extraordinaire
montréal à toronto kitchener waterloo on
ne les entrepreneurs qui veulent bâtir
des sociétés globales comme dax et toute
l'équipe de lightspeed n'y a pas de
raison qu'on ait un light speed ou un
chat pas failli à toutes les quinze ans
au canada on devrait avoir un par année
il faut juste supporter ces sociétés là
pour qu'ils créent les prochains 20 30
40 mille emplois au canada
j'ai une question pour le président du
conseil d'administration de twitter
si vous permettez ce soir toi train qui
est intervenu dans les derniers mois je
vous vois sourire pour réduire la portée
des fausses d'information il ya tout un
travail des médias sociaux qui est
absolument capitale en ce moment et il
ya eu la fermeture du compte dans votre
homme dont tout le monde a parlé sur la
planète terre c'est quoi le rôle de
votre conseil d'administration d'un
conseil d'administration dans des
moments comme ceux comme celui là
d'abord c'est extraordinaire quel
pouvoir participer à l'exercice
démocratique comme on le fait à twitter
c'est vraiment vraiment un privilège
incroyable pour une personne comme moi
du québec de pouvoir être chef du
conseil d'administration d'une société
comme twitter qui est une société de
conséquence c'est pas une grande firme
ans quand j'étais chez google
quand j'ai quitté good 120 employés je
suis tout petit
mais société tellement de conséquences
pour la liberté d'expression pour la
liberté d'information est pour nous
c'est vraiment un point très important
puis l'an dernier mais en fait pour
justin dernier au cours des dernières
années il fallu faire beaucoup
d'investissements sur ce qu'on appelle
la santé du dialogue au lieu de tout se
lancer les casseroles à longueur de
journée il faut faut créer des plafonds
ou est-ce que le dialogue est si vite le
dialogue reste au débat mais toute façon
alors on investit une nouvelle ressource
mais on a quand même des principes très
clairs
un twitter la promotion de la violence
la promotion de la haine toutes ces
choses là se font en sorte que ces des
traders immédiat puis on l'a vu dans les
études américaines ce qu'elles soient
apportées donc vous ne m'en beaucoup
réfléchi à ça au conseil
d'administration il vous monsieur
pochette vous faites partie de la la
profonde réflexion jusqu'à la décision
de fermer un compte comme celui du
président des états unis
en fait toutes ces décisions de gestion
là sont laissés à l'équipe de gestion
oui ça c'est super important dans la
gouvernance nous comme conseil
d'administration on va donner conseils à
l'équipe de gestion notre job c'est de
choisir l'équipe de gestion qui était en
place s'assurer qu'elles qu'ils ont les
bons principes qu'ils ont là les les
bonnes attitudes
puis une fois de suisse a mis en place
il faut les laisser gérer 20 minutes que
toi comme conseils tu commences à gérer
la place c'est comme un chef de plombier
qui sont dans le feu il met toute son
équipe habile alors c'est trouver cet
équilibre qui est conseillé de bien
supporter de poser les bonnes questions
de tester de stresse tester toutes ces
choses là
en bout de ligne les 6 minutes une image
merci beaucoup patrick pichette ton
plaisir de vous recevoir ce soir
merci
toujours un plaisir à bientôt pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici r d